have you ever walked into a really nice
hotel and thought damn this is nice only
to see one problem the fact that you
can't understand why it feels so
captivating even as an architect with
years of experience I have encountered
the same thing it happened on a recent
trip that my wife and I took to
Singapore as we entered our hotel room
at the Como on Oran road we were greeted
by sense of lavender sounds of
waterfalls and the view of a lush Green
Forest I couldn't help but think damn
this is nice and I moved on with my day
it wasn't until later during a moment of
reflection I realized the true magic lay
in the sum of the architectural Parts
combined they enhanced the whole
experience if you want to know how to
recreate this feeling in your own
bathroom through architectural detailing
today we're about to unveil the hidden
elements that turn ordinary spaces into
extraordinary one but wait there is a
small catch along the way I uncovered
some design floors that will'll also
explore together so that you do not make
the same mistakes as they did we dive
deep into 11 stunning architectural
details that will transform your
bathroom into a hotel like Oasis so
let's begin with lighting have you ever
marveled at how certain spaces like
those upscale hotels exud a warm and
welcoming glow without any visible light
sources it's an ageold secret recipe
that I'm about to share with you you see
KO did this with Grace and mystery
greeting you not via traditional harsh
overhead lights but a gentle ambient
glow that seemed to illuminate from
nowhere but everywhere at once I may
sound ridiculous right now but this is
exactly what happens without you even
realizing so let me break it down for
you firstly and most importantly
concealed lighting is about hiding light
sources whilst allowing their Radiance
to shine through it creates a soft
inviting Ambience that Embraces the
overall Aesthetics of the space you see
the magic behind the concealed lighting
lies in the Strategic placement of L
strips within architectural elements
such as recessed niches Coes or even
behind mirrors concealed lighting is the
go-to choice for achieving that
luxurious and Ting atmosphere into your
bathroom it creates Ambience first and
foremost concealed lighting sets the
perfect Ambience it bathes your bathroom
in a soft warm light that is ideal for
relaxing and unwinding it provides
Visual Comfort by Illuminating harsh
shadows and reducing glare and one of
the biggest advantages is design
flexibility you can choose from a
variety of light colors in and styles to
match your bathroom's Aesthetics if
you're wondering how can you actually
use it and incorporate it into your
bathroom well the answer is relatively
simple so let's start with some examples
first of all C lighting isn't lust for
consideration Co lighting used with LED
strips are tucked into recesses or
hidden behind moldings they create a
soft Halo like light along the ceiling
or the baseboard further if you wish to
integrate it to your mirrors integrating
them creates a sleek and functional
solution they provide even illumination
for grooming tasks while also adding A
Touch of Elegance if you have a floating
vanity for a modern twist under
Cabinetry lighting this not only looks
stunning but also creates a sense of
space next let's talk about a touch of
luxury that you can enjoy every day
especially if you have kids have you
ever wondered why hotel room doors close
so effortlessly and quietly making you
feel like royalty as you walk in while
staying at coma Orchard in Singapore did
exactly this the doors closed behind me
with an almost magical like hush which
to be fair is normal for any hotel room
I'll give it that but here's the thing I
I didn't fully appreciate the genius
behind it until I used the bathroom
concealed behind a giant face fixed
sliding door if you can even call it a
door it was actually in the size of the
full wall and it's soft closed for
separation privacy effortlessly if we
decode the magic of soft closing doors
you'll understand how you two can bring
this everyday luxury into your own home
it's all about enhancing your spaces
with both convenience and sophistication
soft closing doors and doors that close
smoothly and silently without standing
shut if you want to use them it's
relatively simple behind the scenes the
hinges do all the work the soft closed
doors are equipped with a specialized
hinge that controls the door's movement
these hinges feature either a hydraulic
damp up or Springs that create
resistance when you close the door as
you gently Push the door it gracefully
Glides to a close the resistance from
the hinges slows down the door's
movement preventing it from slamming
shut so why why are they so important
well soft closed doors offer some
practical benefits for your bathroom
firstly they reduce noise no more door
slamming wakeup calls or disruptions
during the night soft closing doors
maintain their Tranquility of your space
and they enhance the safety if you have
little ones or curious pets soft close
doors add an extra layer of safety they
won't accidentally trap their fingers or
their tails soft closed doors are gentle
on your doors and the frames they
prevent wear and tear extending the
lifespan of your doors and lastly they
contribute to the overall elegant feel
of your space it's a subtle touch that
adds a sense of sophistication if you
ever noticed how some Hotel doors
seamlessly blend with the wall omitting
the traditional doorframe detail this is
what we're discussing in stage three the
moment I entered my room I appreciated
the elegant door frames or lack thereof
it was like stepping into my own
personal Oasis where details are
everything let me explain why it is
essential and without it you've skipped
the rare ingredients in the recipe that
makes it so tasty concealing frames are
all about integrating them into the
doorway and into the overall design of
your bathroom the secret behind this
design choice is a meticulous planning
and craftsmanship they create aesthetic
continuity your bathroom design flows
seamlessly offering a clean unbroken
look and of course they elevate the
Elegance they add a touch of
sophistication make your bathroom feel
like a high-end Spa not to mention the
maintenance is a breeze let's move on
have you ever wondered how some Hotel
showers transport you to a tropical
rainforest making you feel refreshed
let's discover how to shower in luxury
with a simple bathroom upgrade that will
Delight your senses during our stay in
Singapore I found myself under the spell
of a shower that transported me to a
tropical rain forest it wasn't just
about getting clean it was a century
experience that everybody can repres at
home to skip to the good bit the rain
head shower was incredible but what took
it to the next level was the care and
craftsmanship which ensured it was
seamlessly recessed into the ceiling
chances are you already have a rain head
they're quite common now but we can make
it so much better a recess rain head
shower is all about creating a shower
experience that both and versatile it's
like having your own rainforest Retreat
right at home the key to this luxurious
setup is the recessed shower head it
mimics the sensation of standing in a
gentle rain shower providing a soothing
immersive experience and a recess rain
head shower offers some practical
benefits for your bathroom as well it
creates a luxurious rainfall experience
instantly relaxing your senses the
addition of the handheld shower allows
you to easily switch between the rain
head and the targeted showering making
it extremely practical for everyday use
it also creates a sleek and minimalistic
design if I was asked to pause here and
ask a stupid question
like how would you like to have a toilet
that looks like it's floating in midair
sounds cool right well that's exactly
what war hung toilets are and these
toilets are not only sleek and stylish
but they're also practical and space-
saving they're the ultimate bathroom
upgrade that you need to know about of
course the com had this but I noticed
something that bothered me this toilet
wasn't actually floating it was just
mounted on the wall and for me that
means it's so much harder to clean and
maintain than a true loading toilet a
cost cutting exercise sure but one that
they will regret in the near future and
if you're thinking what's the difference
between a war hung and a floating toilet
well a wall hung toilet is a type of
toilet that is attached to the wall but
it still has invisible base or pedestal
a floating toilet is a type of toilet
that is completely recessed into the
wall and also has no visible base or
pedestal and here's why you should opt
for a floating toilet over a wall tub
both types of toilets maximize Space by
eliminating the bulky tank and base but
floating toilet does this even better by
recessing the toilet into the wall you
gain more floor space which can make
your bathroom look bigger and more
spacious both types of toilet make it
easy to clean by having no crevices or
Nooks but a floating toilet does it even
better by having no visible base or
pedestal you can easily sweep or mop
under the toilet ensuring a hygienic and
pristine bathroom at all times again
both toilets exude luxury by having that
sleek in minimalistic design but a
floating toilet you guessed it does it
even better now imagine having the
ultimate tool to turn your bathroom into
a hotel like Oasis a tool that gives you
access to all the secrets tips and
tricks of the trade a tool that saves
you time money and hassle sounds to good
to be true right well guess what it's
not it's real and it's yours for free
for a limited time only I'm giving away
my entire filing system for Architects
contractors and clients absolutely
absolutely free it's an all-in-one
solution use what you want discard what
you don't this is an opportunity you
don't want to miss even if you don't
need it now you will later this offer
expires on November 1st 2023 after that
it will cost you so what are you waiting
for click the link in the video
description below and get instant access
to my complete filing system and if
you're watching this video after the
first November don't worry you can still
get tons of value from my channel just
smash that subscribe button and turn on
the notification Bell so you never miss
out on the next exciting free offerings
and valuable insights in this next
section we're going to look at a design
element that can make or break your
bathroom's Aesthetics I'm talking about
aligning your tiles and when done right
they perfectly align with the features
of your bathroom such as the vanity the
shower or the toilet before I tell you
how to achieve this let's look at a
simple slip up a quick story about how I
discovered the importance of the line
tiles especially feature skirting tiles
St and the challenges of Design
Perfection while had everything but what
really caught my eye was the aligned
contrast skirting tiles to the vanity it
was so Sleek so elegant obviously
considered but then I noticed something
that made me laugh something that showed
me even in a world of precision design
imperfections can occasionally emerge
the skirting tile perfectly aligned with
all of the bathrooms features except one
the shower seat was just a Tad too low
in both terms of usability and design
language resulting in the skirting tile
cutting the bench in half instead of
perfectly aligning underneath it's such
a small detail but it makes such a big
difference so what's the lesson here
well the aligned tiled skirtings are not
just about Aesthetics they're also about
functionality and precision they're a
design choice that requires meticulous
planning and attention to detail so
let's continue our journey and explore a
design element that goes beyond
Aesthetics triggering memories and
emotions I'm talking about tile patterns
with a personal connection these are
tile patterns that resonate with your
past experiences spaces or moments they
Infuse your bathroom with a sense of
nostalgia and personal significance but
before I tell you how to achieve this
look let me explain the power of a tile
pattern there's a reason I keep coming
back to the coma example their tile
pattern in this case was nearly
identical to the one at Ko in where I
recently got married it was such a sweet
surprise it made me feel like I was
reliving one of the happiest days of my
life so what's the lesson here well it's
that tile patterns with a personal
connection are not just about Aesthetics
they're a design choice that can make
your bathroom more than just a
functional space they can make it a
reflection of who you are and what
matters to you these patterns will
always envelop you in Nostalgia they'll
transport brought you to a cherish
memory and a space from your past making
you feel happy and grateful they create
emotional resilience every time you step
into your bathroom you're greeted by
memories and feelings that make the
space Uniquely Yours it's very simple to
select a tile pattern that holds a
personal significance start by
reflecting on your own memories think
about spaces or moments from your past
that evoke positive emotions it could be
your childhood home your favorite
vacation spot or your wedding venue
explore these tile patterns that
resemble or remind you of those memories
moving on to Stone selections with
design continuity do you want to make
your bathroom look like a million
dollars then you need to pay attention
to this design element that can
transform your space from ordinary to
extraordinary I'm of course talking
about Stone selections with designed
continuity this is when you use the same
stone for the vanity and other elements
in your bathroom creating a seamless and
luxurious look look every stone has its
own character and charm when you choose
a stone that matches your bathroom's
theme and your personal taste you create
a visual Harmony that resonates
throughout the entire space Here's the
beauty of it by using the same stone for
the vanity and extending it to other
elements you achieve a level of
sophistication and elegance that is
truly unmatched often people choose to
mix and match Stones throughout the
house but this can be really challenging
to pull off without the help of a
professional therefore when you're
matching your Stones you should aim to
create cohesion the consistent use of
the stone creates a visual thread that
ties every element seamlessly together
you can create luxurious ambulance
through the use of natural beauty and
elegance of stone selections that
elevate the overall Aesthetics of your
bathroom when done right you establish
an elegant design language that
continues to communicate sophistication
make sure the stone selects even the
subtle details in your bathroom like the
toilet roll shelf this continuity of
stone demonstrates an unwavering
commitment to design Excellence now if
you want to make your bathroom look like
a master piece of design then pay
attention threshold changes within a
space can create functional and
significant changes these are the
transitions from one area to another in
your bathroom such as from your main
area to the shower they can communicate
the function of each space and add
elegance and safety to your bathroom
imagine you're walking through a museum
admiring different artworks each artwork
has its own style its own theme and its
own message but how do you know where
one art piece ends and another begins
simple by looking at the frames the
frames separate each artwork from the
others creating clear boundaries and
transitions now think about your
bathroom as a museum each area is his
own artwork how do you separate each
area from the other by creating clear
boundaries and transitions by using
thresholds these thresholds are like
frame Nam for your bathroom areas
creating clear boundaries clear
transitions let's move on do you want to
make your bathroom look like a secret
agents Lair we can with these storage
solutions that are hidden behind mirrors
within cabinets or secret drawers they
all offer functionality and Intrigue
within your bathroom imagine you're in a
mission to find a hidden treasure in an
ancient Temple you enter a room that
looks like any other you discover hidden
compartments secret passages and conceal
Clues it's like a puzzle that reveals
its Secrets as you solve it that's how I
felt when I entered the coma bathroom it
felt like a normal bathroom until I
explored until I discovered the hidden
storage behind the mirrors within the
Cabinetry and of course within the seek
of drawers it was like a treasure hunt
that revealed its Secrets as I used it
so why a creative and Secret Story
solution so important and how can you
achieve them in your own bathroom well
creative and Secret Story Solutions are
designed choice that not only adds value
and visual interest but also creates a
sense of cohesion and luxury in your
bathroom these Solutions are all about
maximizing space whilst keeping clutter
out of sight they add an element of
surprise to your bathroom where every
cabinet or drawer conceals a hidden
treasure the beauty of it is by using
creative and secret Storage Solutions
you achieve a level of sophistication
and elegance that is truly unmatched
often for little more cost than regular
storage so concealing a itional storage
helps keep your bathroom organized and
clutter free lastly we need to focus on
the material palette this is when you
use high quality materials and colors
inspired by Nature creating a sense that
stands creating a space that stands the
test of time nature is our best source
of inspiration so you imagine you're
walking through a forest admiring the
beauty of nature you see the lights
shining through the trees the rich
colors of the leaves and the textures of
the bark you feel a sense of peace and
Harmony so why is a material palette
with Timeless Elegance so important well
it's an interesting question because it
creates a sense of cohesion and luxury
once again in your bathroom which is the
overarching moral of the story anyway
that's all from me team if you enjoyed
the video consider subscribing down
below for new weekly content